how are you Elle tea fun are you in New
York City are you in NYC right now still
or no no I couldn't get this right my
flight got canceled obviously the huge
storm he called Arctic bomb cyclone
northeast yeah no yeah cyclone woman
something like that but no I wasn't able
to get there so I'm in Texas okay so you
know I know you're you're coming here on
behalf of FedEx and we'll talk about
that in a second and you're getting
ready for the weekend you got kids and
all that stuff but you know ESPN
published a piece just last night and
today saying essentially that Brady and
Belichick are not on the same page
anymore Garoppolo as part of the rift
so was the trainer situation that
happened and that this could be and that
there's a general sense around that
building that this is the end for Brady
and Belichick as we've known it and I'd
love to get your thoughts on that
LT yeah I think it's very interesting
because you know for the longest this
organization has always been very
measured in what they put out what they
say and and you know this rich every
time we talk to a Patriots player they
sound the same way in everything that
they say it's all the same and that's
because of Bill Belichick I find it
ironic now that all these things are
starting to come out when you know when
the talk has been about Bill Belichick
kind of taking taking privileges away
from Alex Guerrero who is Tom Brady's
trainer
so now all of a sudden that means to all
the distension and and the different
things that are going on with the
organization right now when they have
always been organization that have had
things under wraps and nothing gets out
and we know we know these things happen
in every organization it does but they
have done a good job of keeping these
things in the locker room no longer is
it stay
in the locker room now why is that well
is it because of Bill Belichick or is it
because of perhaps some of the things
that have happened of late have allowed
the guys to say you know what I'm tired
of this I'm gonna talk about it and
that's why these stories are starting to
come out is there have you ever been
around a locker room where somebody's
personal trainer essentially became part
of the staff is this something that's it
sounds completely unusual to me but I'm
just wondering uh what you could tell me
el-tee it is unusual something like this
and and I to have Alex Guerrero as my
guy when I play Alice Carell will fly
out to San Diego every week after the
game to work on me for a couple of days
and Danny would take off to New England
that has been going on for years so he
has been a part of that organization but
he had more access to that organization
obviously that he had with the charges
he had to come to my home which the
charges you know he couldn't come to the
complex and so I've never seen an
organization give access to an outside
individual like they have but I find it
ironic now that all of a sudden Bill
Belichick doesn't want him around and he
has too much access hmm so there's some
there there right LT I mean so let me
ask you this absolutely but do you
believe it's going I think it could be
you know that bill started to feel like
he no longer had a grip on the players
and what no not really controlling them
but making sure they were managed in the
right way making sure the stories stayed
in-house things were starting to leak
and come apart and maybe that's why he
felt like you need to make some changes
LT LaDainian Tomlinson here on the Rich
Eisen show all right let's talk about
teams that are actually playing this
weekend which of the teams are playing
this weekend there's eight of them
Titans Chiefs Falcons Rams bills Jaguars
Panthers Saints do you think has the run
in them to go wild card to podium to
pick and confetti out of their hair in
Minnesota
LT
I think it's I think it's the Saints
when I look at that football team for
one offensively they are able to score
multiple ways everybody know that you
know most of the year they have relied
on that run game but Drew Brees is still
back there calling the plays he's still
throwing the football and so he's going
to make timely plays for their football
team we need it defensively they have
played better over the over the course
of the year secondary has gotten better
so they're being a little bit more
aggressive on defense I like the way
they're playing I can see them going on
and on now you can say you know in the
AFC and I really like Jacksonville's
defense but I'm not a believer in what
they're doing on offense I don't think
they're consistent enough with Blake
bortles
and Leonard fournette to be able to move
the football and score points against
the likes of Pittsburgh Steelers or the
New England Patriots so I would say the
Saints are the most likely team to make
a deep run
yeah what's Gurley doing that's so damn
impressive man to you you've seen it all
LaDainian or see him Saturday night yeah
yeah you know which is really the
combination of his size speed and
agility you know when you think about
that that total package in a guy like
girl is for one when you look at a man
of God is huge man it looks like a
linebacker you know but then when you
see him in open field he's running away
from cornerbacks you know and then his
ability to think that he's gonna you
think he's gonna run over you what does
he do Alma just sleep over you like it's
nothing and I love his involvement in
the passing game that's to me dig that's
what gets me excited his involvement in
the past and we know he can run the
football but where he's truly dangerous
is getting him out in space in the
passing game and certainly Sean McVeigh
has done a terrific job with that
is he an MVP though as I asked one of
the few running back MVPs in recent
years is he the MVP well
yeah I mean you know I think he's in
strong consideration I don't think he
will win it because in order to win the
MVP at the running back position man you
you have to have broken a record I've
done some extremely rare and just I mean
you look at the last four MVPs at the
running back position Marshall Faulk he
broke the touchdown record Sean
Alexander we set the touchdown record
myself reset the touchdown record and
Adrian Peterson ran for 2,000 yards and
almost set a single-season rushing
record those are the last four MVPs at
the running back position and I'm afraid
that because Todd hasn't done that he's
going to be left out at the end of the
day to win out of 1mm LaDainian
Tomlinson here on the Rich Eisen show
and the FedEx air and ground NFL player
of the year awards coming up on honors
but voting opens if I'm not mistaken
that's that's today correct voting today
okay what can fans do yeah so in order
to vote via Twitter using hashtag hash
hash tag burying ground scuse me and at
nfl.com for slash FedEx they can vote
and voting will be will close on
Thursday February first and as you
mentioned the winners will be announced
Saturday February 3rd and NFL honors
mm-hmm ask him a poll question before we
get out the door here with uh with LT
Chris Brock dannion who's most likely to
end their career with the Patriots
Belichick Brady neither hmm I'm gonna
say I'm gonna say Brady III think I
think this rift is real and I think it
can cause Bill Belichick to leave after
this year and you know he might say you
know mr. Kraft I appreciate it but you
can have your Brady and I'm moving on
I'm telling you their fault and there is
a job open with the Giants that is the
one he would
Neven spend a split-second energy I
agree I agree which that's a very good
point because he has history with their
organization I can so see him going to
New York I can overall net football team
second overall pick he likes Josh Rosen
if he likes Josh Rosen go get him start
again yeah right yeah or hold on a
second
yeah I agree or-or-or Belichick stays
put finds another quarterback and Brady
finishes his career with the Jets what
do you think he'll take I don't think
Brady I don't think he will go to the
Jets
yeah like you kidding me he won't go
there where would he wear what he even
wear an Arizona Arizona okay play with
Larry Fitzgerald
I just don't know guys yeah but this is
a fun game though isn't it maybe too
Brown LT I'll see you at the shop thanks
for calling okay okay thank you you got
it Pro Football Hall of Famer at LT
underscore 21 on Twitter Rich Eisen show
weekdays at noon eastern on audience